my friends once arrested and twice
impeached failed former president Donald
Trump is about to get arrested again and
this time it appears federal charges are
coming Trump's lawyers meeting with the
justice department yesterday reportedly
begging them please please with tears in
their eyes don't charge Donald Trump CBS
news reports Trump attorneys meet with
special counsel at justice department
amid documents investigation great
report by Robert Costa and others
attorneys representing Trump met with
special counsel Jack Smith and
prosecutors at the justice department 10
a.m yesterday according to two people
familiar with the matter this took place
weeks after Trump's lawyers requested a
meeting with top federal law enforcement
officials the attorneys for Trump spent
just under two hours inside the Maine
Justice building and declined to comment
as they left
CBS News cameras captured Trump's legal
team walking in the former president's
lawyers did not speak as they entered a
person familiar with the meeting between
the three attorneys and the department
said Merrick Garland was not there two
people familiar with the probe say
Trump's legal team is frustrated with
how the justice department has handled
attorney-client matters in recent months
and would likely raise concerns during
the meeting in particular prosecutors
discussions of related issues in front
of the grand jury
um additional reporting from The
Washington Post Trump lawyers ask
justice department not to charge Trump
in the classified documents case we now
have reporting here about the reason for
the visit quote attorneys for Donald
Trump went to the justice department
Monday to make their case the government
should not charge the former president
in connection with his possession of
classified documents after leaving
office as reported already in the other
article they were there for two hours
Merritt Garland wasn't there justice
department has not commented this is an
interesting paragraph while it is not
uncommon in high profile cases for
defense lawyers to get such a meeting
with Justice Department officials
towards the end of an investigation
current and former officials say such
presentations rarely change prosecutors
Minds two Trump advisors briefed on
Monday's meeting say they continue to
believe Smith will file analyze a
charging decision in coming weeks the
advisors say they are preparing for a
potential indictment of the former
president the meeting did not change
their expectations Donald Trump by all
reasonable reports is about to get
arrested again indicted again this time
on federal charges these aren't even the
only federal charges Trump might be
charged for remember that there is a
federal investigation into Trump's
mishandling of classified documents
which we now know took place not only at
Mar-A-Lago but also at Bedminster we now
know Trump knew they were classified
based on an audio recording of trump
saying I have a document here but I
can't show it to you because it's
classified which confirms Trump knew he
had not actually Declassified the
documents that's one slate of federal
charges that could be coming
in addition there are the potential
charges referred to the justice
department by the former house committee
investigating the insurrectionist Trump
Riots of January 6 2021 that could lead
to charges and in addition to that
Fannie Willis in Georgia will be making
a charging decision on state level
charges against Trump sometime between
July and September when the next grand
jury is reconvened and those decisions
are going to be made we could see one
two or even three additional arrests of
the once arrested twice impeached former
president just over the summer the
question we are all now asking is
whether this will impact Trump's
campaign for the Republican candidacy
and who of the other people running for
the Republican candidacy or the
Republican nomination stand to benefit
the most it seems It's DeSantis because
he's the only one in double digits at
this point in terms of the polling but
we'll look at that a little more deeply
probably Thursday if not Friday in the
meantime Trump's reaction to news that
he will likely be arrested completely
and totally unhinged I've had such
trouble finding a great razor where I am
not cutting myself or getting those
Nicks on my skin which are so common
with the cheap disposable razors you
have to meet our sponsor Henson shaving
Henson actually manufactures parts for
the International Space Station and the
Mars rover and they are bringing that
exact same Precision Engineering to the
Shaving experience it hurts when you
shave because blades extend too far and
thus they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below